[Music]
so uh you're a football fan are you guys
do you guys follow sports at all i gave
up on sports when i got into politics
okay can't support those losers i don't
know anything about sports at all
outside of like combat sports like mixed
martial arts hockey is a little
a little bit not so much anymore since i
stayed away from canada yeah but uh we
do a segment now uh just because people
think that i'm exaggerating the super
bowl did you guys follow super bowl yeah
i want a super bowl i watched it on the
phone okay so see i didn't so this so
this is a segment now that we call
stephen knowsports
[Music]
all right so explain this one to us
token now in the game for people who
don't know
yeah so we're going to ask you a few
questions um these are all super bowl
related for the special these are all
super bowl related questions yeah yeah
oh well okay there are a few that are
just just okay there are a few just
trying to give me a fighting chance for
the record
i did not watch the super bowl
i do not know anything about the super
bowl i don't even know the teams that
were involved super bowl i just know
that there was a commercial uh with
wayne's world because it showed up on my
uber etap that was actually kind of fun
the term concubine
because it's a salad disgusting human
being sorry
[Laughter]
sweetheart it's not advised that you go
on instagram and talk about cleaning
your ankle with your acrylic nails
what kind of teenage angst is this oh my
gosh shot it sounds like cartman
[Laughter]
okay so these are questions i wouldn't i
watched nothing with the super bowl and
uh you can play along with me then we'll
be taking your chat if you think that
i'm i swear to you how much do i know
about sports none none okay zero i will
one hundred percent he's not lying this
is not a good job all right let's see
okay
what is it first question all right
first question we got uh which of these
players is known as the brady slayer
having defeated tom brady twice in the
super bowl and we got multiple choice a
paid manning b eli manning c your
favorite drew brees
and d brett favre okay that's because
they're saying that because i spelled
drew brees like febreze
with a z with a z okay here's the thing
i know tom brady okay and the reason i
know tom brady is because i got a pair
of the tom brady pajamas for uh
christmas
came with a picture of him they're
actually really comfortable
so here's what i i don't know anything
about drew brees but i know that you
said he's really good to okinawan uh
helen do you guys know the answer to
that dude okay don't give me the answer
i know it's not brett favre because he
wasn't he like sort of passed his prime
sending dick pics by the time tom brady
was really taking names he throws too
many interceptions too does he okay
brett favre well he's he's handling the
ball
as they say and that's probably such a
good thrower because it's the only ball
that's not round
if you were playing golf you wouldn't
know what to do no victimhood i'm going
to say here okay i'm narrowing it down
to a or c why because from what i
understand and only because i've seen
peyton manning host reason now
eli manning is the lesser manning like
the like the dylan brother on entourage
he is the lesser manning from what i
understand and it comes down to a peyton
manning or c drew brees um
i uh but i feel like peyton manning was
sort of wasn't he sort of at his tail
end while tom brady was coming yeah he
had some serious neck issues wasn't it
like peyton manning was kind of aging
yeah as tom brady was coming up i mean
they kind of played at the same time tom
brady's been playing for like 22 years
right but wouldn't like drew brees be
playing more at the second half of tom
brady and peyton manning would be
playing in the first half i think all
three of those guys are about the same
age about the same so peyton manning is
98.99 so he's only a couple years behind
okay i know it's either a or c but uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna go uh by narrowing
it down
uh
c drew brees incorrect yeah
i wasn't right that was great
but wrong answer right you actually are
regular eli is the lesser manning but
for some reason he beats brady
he's the lesser man he has more super
bowl wins though right same uh yeah the
same i think they have the same same now
it's like rock paper scissors and
sometimes it's like you know matchups
make fights in mma where you can have
two guys where one guy will beat the guy
like 10 out of 10 times yeah and that
guy will beat this other guy 10 out of
10 times but he'll beat the first guy
like two out of 10 times just a
stylistic matchup okay so now i wouldn't
know eli manning if he walked up and bit
me on the ass i wouldn't know what he
looks like he unless he looks out
striking like peyton manning would you
know many people by how they [ __ ] you
in the ass
pete but i have to put out a restraining
order
the guy just doesn't understand like
like it's his thing but it's not mine
yeah
it's really awkward next question number
two
all right number two which of these
teams has never won a super bowl
b the raiders see the jets or d the
vikings okay no it's not the rams isn't
that las vegas
uh
los angeles i know angelus now yeah okay
so i know it's not i know it's not the
raiders because i remember when i played
for the greenfield park packers as a kid
i played football we won and we won
provincials we won that's like winning
state we won provincials like 60
something to nothing wow because and
that's just a perfect example of getting
reps and we practiced four times a week
and then we did a warm-up before the
game and so we just
so we were the green greenfield park
packers so naturally we prefer the green
bay packers and if i remember correctly
i think was the raiders beat the packers
kind of in their peak wasn't it like it
went one year packers next year raiders
damn though i think you're right i know
the raiders don't know so okay so i
narrowing it down to the jets and the
vikings and from what i understand the
jets are really bad and it's kind of
like they're not as bad as detroit lions
so if that were here i could have said
lions obviously um
i'm gonna go see the jets have you ever
heard of somebody called
broadway joe
i was trying to help you out a little
bit really famous
video of him going into the yeah
yeah
he kind of called joe montana no joe
namath
he did the muhammad ali with the 70s
season quarterback yeah jack jack
quarterback
so they're saying the jets did win a
super bowl yeah okay the vikings
this is the kind of help stephen needs
to get the answer correct he is not
joking i don't feel like these are easy
questions no well i mean you know
relatively i didn't know this one okay
well that's fair see that's good i got
this one
yeah we got an easy one for you coming
up now okay
of all time i couldn't even do that
yes you i honestly couldn't name enough
wasn't it that wasn't the purple people
leaders didn't they can name one yeah um
i'm okay i'm just gonna have to take a
guess okay i'll google the name of a
name of a very big black man
okay
so i'm gonna start
big black
i'm gonna start with jerome
okay and i'm gonna go with
jerome
that's not a black man named it's a
black name oh no damn football
okay no no no no
jerome is not a black person there you
go
what's the common black person last name
i know like smith
white jackson
jackson jackson okay something jackson
jackson something jackson they're saying
jerome's not a black person name i don't
know
um
something jackson i'm trying to think uh
something jaqen uh jackson uh jackson
marcus jackson oh that's a good one
that's a good i feel like that's marcus
jackson
and he's a wife
[Laughter]
marcus jackson marcus look listen listen
listen people don't like generalizations
and stereotypes they can save your life
[Laughter]
marcus jackson can we get on the show
you came up marcus jackson wow well now
i can't name my son i want to name one
of my sons uh marcus aurelius and
hillary my wife was like marcus is a
black person no
wow did you just call your wife
no she just said it would be weird like
she's known any white guy i've never
known a white guy named marcus
really yeah
i've known a few black guys named marcus
i actually really like the name marcus
yeah yeah uh they've added to it now now
it's demarcus
that's right they do that a lot like
like uh uh deandre yeah dion
d keith delinquent
that's what
the d is for that's what the crew that's
what the creditors yeah i'm about to
steal that one
go for it put it in your act i can't do
it and
flood the stage
hey have you ever noticed that black
people have a d in front of the man
it's not going to go well it's beyond
liquid oh
there's gonna be a bunch of angry
anti-hipsters throwing craft beer
got the ipa in my eye
high gravity question number four
question number four okay we always
gotta have an mma oh which of these
fighters did not play in the nfl brenham
shaw brock lesnar greg hardy derrick
lewis i know brock lesnar did uh the
things with brendan shut brennan shaub
did play but i think he was benched and
i don't know if it was derek i'm gonna
go greg hardy this is one that i'm not
entirely sure it could be derek lewis or
greg hardy because i think all of them
played football but and this was
something two mma were like there aren't
a level athletes in mma and actually
they had some people who came from from
football and brock lesnar was a high
high level athlete yeah but people were
saying no you don't see great athletes
in mma that's why it's just a brawl
because you know they go to more uh
lucrative sports um but that's not
really true you've had a lot of
professional athletes from other sports
come in and they just don't like getting
punched in the face it's a very
different thing getting punched in the
face yeah than it is you know going out
there and being hit with pads so i'm
going to say see greg hardy it's either
greg hardy or derrick lewis
did play in college okay he played in
college yeah and most of these guys
benched uh actually you know what that's
incorrect brock lesnar didn't play in
the nfl
lesnar did he played for no he tried out
seattle he tried out he didn't make it
he was on a practice squad so
technically no no no no no that's a
that's a question he never shooted up
and played again look it up token owen
and i knew that and i gave you a pass
because you were trying to trick me well
you didn't say that played well played
in the nfl does that mean you actually i
don't even think he was on a practice
squad really yeah i don't think he was
and i think he got man handled he or the
boss or whatever that seattle guy the
two guys who i know he yeah he he was on
the vikings no
he played in the game it looks like
really
okay well i know matt matrione and
brendan show i think matt mitchell was
one who actually played the most in the
nfl i didn't know the shot one so yeah
it wasn't very tough no it wasn't very
good much like his podcast hosting
ability
worst stand-up special i've ever seen
special
yeah in the loosest sense of the word
yeah where is it at netflix or uh
they're probably fine it's on show time
show time that's on show time just look
for the cover with the full-grown man
dressed like justin bieber
all right how many more questions do we
have we got two more okay two more and
then we gotta go chat
all right who is the super bowl champion
i don't know
is that marcus
i have i honestly i have no idea who
that is i i couldn't i couldn't i have
no idea is this just this super bowl
champion
can you pronounce it juju smith shuster
that's not a real name
it is not a real name it is yes it is oh
i don't believe it it's not what he goes
by this is this is his name
that's his name it's a long one he's
like he's paulie his name is juju yeah
but he's really good too yeah really
good he's polynesian i think he's like
half black half polynesian okay that was
awesome if any of the commercials his
fish it's not samuel l jackson for
talking smack to him really yeah
this sounds like a face that's actually
kind of funny none of this makes sense
lucy juju is his name
juju smith schuster what is he a
somalian pirate no but he's polynesian
so i mean i'd be careful oh god they'll
come after you juju
that's jewish final football
no hebrew oh no all right omar you can't
watch the super bowl anymore can't let
her near the screen quiet right one more
this is the last one here we go all
right final one so who is sarah thomas
would she a the first woman to referee a
super bowl be the first woman to coach
in a super bowl see the first super bowl
champion to transition to being a woman
or d the first woman to play in a super
bowl okay so it's not c or d
okay
this is the easy one man well either
coach or referee but women wouldn't want
to wear the uniform so
i'm going to assume why because stripes
yeah well if she's short you know maybe
she thinks it's it's slimming it makes
her look taller
so you guys know this one keith kevin
yeah it's pretty uh self-explanatory uh
okay i'm gonna say that she's out the
first sexist first woman to coach in a
super bowl b
how is that self-explanatory no women
coaches
i don't know they're driving there too
they let them drive cars nowadays yeah
in your defense assistant health
secretary there was an assistant coach
for san francisco i think had an
assistant just going to be just going to
be some coach out there with rachel
levine i call the defense
i was at a super bowl party yesterday
he's like yeah because that's what we
need another woman telling men what
they're doing wrong
it's true there was a there was a female
referee in mma kim
kim something
poor thing was just
fell out of the elderly tree hit every
stick on the way down
yeah yeah and she was too like she just
she would let fights go on way too long
and then she like she wasn't aggressive
enough so guys would be pounding guys
out after unconscious and she's like
can you stop like no
so she got into a lot of trouble i don't
think she i don't think she referees a
whole lot anymore you pretty much have
to be a fighter to be a ref to be able
to jump in there sometimes
you remember that yeah i have to stop
looking at man just throwing me off
like the oscar mayer wiener kid on the
dock yeah man but uh she she came to our
meet and greet after the show she had a
fat ass
that's because there's nowhere else for
it to grow the proportions are all oh
that's that
did you tell it did you compliment her i
just smiled at him
you didn't tell her she got a fat ass
like a nice fat i think uh uh
she probably would have made her day
yeah yeah was she black no she's not
she's white this is sweet yeah sweden i
don't know i assume that all countries
are as diverse as the united states no
that place is i felt really safe in that
country number one white people
no immigrants there they literally know
i ain't seen none you guys have a lot of
fans in sweden oh yeah
i don't know about now that's before we
came out politically do you see do you
see did you see you didn't see a lot of
black people at all in sweden i see none
you didn't see a single one maybe one
did people look at you differently there
like no they're really nice
cool yeah okay well they just talked
about when you left
there's like a novelty they're like oh
they do exist well that's a perfect
example like people talk about like
sweden and then they talk about
norwegian countries denmark and first
off you're comparing a country to the
size of the state of new jersey and it's
very homogenous like to act as though
their policies are going to be the same
there that you could enact in a country
of 300 plus million united states people
here come from different backgrounds and
have different values anyway i don't
know i'm still talking okay this has
been steven knows sports
all right let's do three rapid fire
chats cause we gotta go all right great
so braden g wants to know steven do you
know any actual pro-american musicians
to listen to now that i hate bruce
[Laughter]
um
gosh i you know it's tough outside of
like you know conservative
self-proclaimed musicians but like um
uh
well lil wayne um you got alice cooper
who's uh like a christian
and he's about as good as it gets um
who else uh who else i'm trying to think
uh kiss you want to come two singers
kiss a lot of metal guys yeah yeah like
kiss like a lot a lot of them are
conservative yeah
yeah metal hard rock a lot of those guys
are more conservative than people
realize how about countries like i think
country is very phony
like you see it um well it's like
hollywood in nashville yeah like i've
been around a lot of them are just
really kind of liberal and they just
like they have to pander to the
demographic but there are some who are
true
you know so i'm sure there's some in
country but um i mean i assume you guys
know country that
take the bulk of it but yeah outside of
that metal a lot of the classic rockers
is a and then a lot of the hip-hop guys
you got who did you have yeah lil wayne
you had uh pitbull anybody
yeah anybody that donald trump pardoned
any of the rappers
yeah exactly to be in the next pitbull
video
all right let's go to the other okay mrs
conservative teacher wants to know as an
employer and an entrepreneur what skills
would you want future employees to have
that a teacher like myself can develop
in practice
what what would i want my employees to
have yeah what skills are you most
looking for you we're all business
owners so you can tell me i will tell
you this you cannot teach attitude
that's one thing that i will say you
need to find i've found that if you have
someone who's hyperly technical and
capable but they don't really have the
work ethic or attitude or drive that it
doesn't really work you need to find the
intersect of someone who is technically
very capable proficient but the person
who is technically good enough with an
attitude and a work ethic and
self-discipline will almost always
surpass that expert in a short amount of
time and certainly surpass your
expectations as an employer when
compared to someone who just sort of has
that technical wherewithal what would
you say so now that you take you took
that one that was a very good one um
just the ability to problem solve yes
it's unbelievable how many people if
they get outside of their defined field
of what they know is step three and four
and five just freeze when some weird
problems don't you just hate to because
you guys too like don't you just hate it
when you have an employee who brings you
like well who's who happens like a
problem and you're like yeah they create
products and you're like well okay
[Laughter]
i want you to show some initiative yeah
about that yeah that's why people love
to hate business owners it's like well
why doesn't he if he's so smart when you
do it like he probably did it for years
and he hired you so he could expand and
hire more of you right and you're
supposed to do the job yeah problem
solving is huge huge i think there's a
book i don't know what's the cool thing
uh pop scrouter it's called like the red
vase or something it's just this guy
would send it's basically someone would
send someone out and even if it didn't
exist find this i think it's it's red
vase something vase it's basically about
sending someone out for something
arbitrary just to see if they can do it
yeah exactly figure it out yeah and
that's what i would say the big
difference is between business owners
and a lot of uh employees that is never
quite appreciated is when you are out
there and you're taking a risk and it's
your own money right you have to solve
problems you do not have the luxury of
saying well this happened but that's not
my job you don't have that luxury no
because ultimately you're the ones who
have to be on air ultimately you're the
ones who have to be on stage right same
thing you can't say that right
ultimately that wine has to be at the
dinner ultimately those people need to
get their shipment and i can't say that
i can't be like well okay this doesn't
uh i don't know i couldn't figure out
the source so bye
and so
that's the class warfare that's really
dangerous to me is pitting employees
against business owners whereas business
owners listen they want to grow and
employ more people and of course they
want to do well for themselves but right
everyone here knows like i know the way
you treat your employees i don't know
the way you treat but i assume you treat
them the way you treat other people
pretty well we all want our employees to
do well yeah but we also don't want our
lives to be overburdened with stress if
employees aren't you know
if they're not if they're not if they're
not
yeah stop talking about me man you and
lawrence what would you what would you
say hodge twins best quality for an
employee yeah i guess initiative and
they don't need a lot of assistance they
don't they don't
they pretty much can figure it out on
their own yeah yeah yeah i just i mean i
had that issue with that i'm not going
but they
we didn't have any problems when we was
just running they were like when we
hired them to take over our role they
created problems right right it's like
made everything so much harder supposed
to make my life a lot easier not a great
problem right yeah exactly yeah and
that's a big so that's one thing look
think of if you also want to uh you know
get yourself in your bosses good graces
here's just be compassionate and like
see what maybe he needs that's a big
thing too or she or she
or z
but really because as bosses you don't
get a lot of pats in the back you always
have to encourage employees and hey good
this is great hey
thank you for doing that right and then
sometimes just like this is your problem
they put on your desk and just listen if
you want maybe it's your i don't know if
you're what you mean by teacher maybe
it's the principal maybe it's the dean
whoever your superior is but yeah take
initiative problem solve and know that
there's someone else who probably has
more responsibilities than you which
means probably more stresses than you
and see what there is that you can help
them with and i guarantee you that will
go a long way not all bosses are far
left democrat ebenezer scrooge
pre-redemption one more chat okay final
one comes from blah blah blah
why do you think democrats like to
victimize themselves so often because
it's currency and it's the most valuable
currency there is there is nothing more
desirable than today's democrat party
than to be a victim accomplishments nay
self-discipline nay virtues who gives a
[ __ ] i need the victim card today this
question i'm a petite female
and fortunately i trained jiu jitsu
currently at purple congratulations but
i still find myself concerned that i can
be viewed as a target for attack when
i'm in public i'm seriously considering
purchasing a firearm do you have any
advice for a first-time purchaser and
also for someone like myself it was a
healthy fear of guns
uh yeah you know this is actually a good
question by the way congratulations
purple belt and jiu jitsu
is no joke
i would love uh maybe this person can
send a follow-up
um and we could see uh where they train
what they do purple belt and jiu-jitsu
for people out there who are like my
daughter has a black belt uh it means
that your check cleared yeah purple belt
and jiu-jitsu is equivalent to a black
people in any other art you're coming up
for
four to six years
um if you're training three times a week
two time two hours each training session
and it's a hundred i can't i'm happy
every woman out there should know jiu
jitsu every single one of them yeah
should know jiu-jitsu and have a gun
right so she's doing the two things that
you can do to make sure that you're safe
three things three things third i want
every woman out there to no jiu-jitsu
right know how to fight there's a gracie
uh combative that the rape defense court
yeah is really useful a firearm and uh i
want every woman should know they need i
would like to develop a training tool uh
so that they can drill indian sunburning
of penis ah that's true oh that's rough
feature rape defense course where it's
about clenching the seats and ripping it
off real tight oh really dave mm-hmm
only you followed through on that threat
it never works
if you shove that in my ear i'll bite
you indian sunburn just
[Music]
um because apparently if you're being
sexually assaulted by jerry lewis hey
lady
um which happened to a lot of ways into
a lot i have no doubt fortunately let's
get in the green room rather than live
uh i think
a firearm so look this is a good thing
too uh frank mirror who's a ufc champion
he's always carrying he like carries an
absurd amount of cares like two guns and
three knives jon jones uh hoyce gracie
said on the in the street he would use a
gun this is one of those myths that
people have they go you need a gun
because you're a coward uh no the
toughest guys in the boss root who's
been on the show says of course i carry
a gun because i'm not an idiot right
he's belgium so um
thanks for clarifying yeah it really
does come down to the fact that it's
just not worth the risk again you have
people who are delusional who say i
don't use a gun i use my windshield well
look
nothing is foolproof you can be a world
champion you can be a you can be a
boxing belt holder you can be a jiu
jitsu you can be an mma and still you
can find examples of people like b.j
penn lightweight champ knocked out in a
bar fight he was drunk got caught by
surprise something happened with don fry
and lobby's one of the toughest guys
alive
things go wrong in street fights it's
never beautiful or choreographed so i
still recommend that everybody have a
firearm and
always avoid violence at all costs until
you're at the point where there is no
other available option in which case you
make it as swift as effective as
possible to stop the threat as quickly
as possible that's why you don't shoot
the leg that's why you don't just do the
slap in the kung fu it's nope nothing
nothing nothing hey you're right you
kick my ass hey you're right hey yep you
take my wife whatever words are just
words
and then once it gets to the point where
you have to defend yourself
you make it count that's my that's my
worldview now with a firearm i would say
uh avoid actually going really small
with firearms a lot of women say i want
a small gun those are really hard to
shoot they're really snappy like some of
the small 380s are a lot snappier than
some of the nine millimeters um i would
recommend you know i like revolvers
they're pretty easy to use i would
recommend getting a small but heavy
revolver or of course if you're going
semi-automatic look i'm biased wall
through them uh their walther pps is
great and it has a little laser on it on
the grip which makes it really easy
because people aren't looking down the
sights
it's really safe it has a relatively
heavy trigger pull super simple to use
has good capacity and it's not nearly as
snappy as a lot of little nine
millimeters um and you could easily you
know carry it on your person or put it
in your purse which is usually
ill-advised unless you have your purse
on you at all times like brian stelter
yeah absolutely no i have one of those
and that's a great way to use it um in
first if
no yeah i have said
no i have a lot of pps okay liberace no
i have what else were you going to say
purse man i was going to say that you're
right that
now i can't even think of what i'm going
to say because now i'm the purse man and
that's going to stick yeah sure
purse man has a point
it's a perfect gun in the purse and then
hit him with it
make sure it's a heavy gun so it doesn't
like it i have no other point you don't
have any other points all right you've
successfully forwarded all right i guess
we can go to another you're thinking of
your other points now you see how hard
it is when you guys goof off and i have
to stick with my with my points well we
do it because you're good at
this wouldn't be a it for you if we
didn't give you some curveballs that's
true that's true curveballs like
stelter's penis
what gets curved in the purse curve then
balls i think roll them up like your
t-shirts when you go on a long trip
terrible all right so kevin kevin has
switching gears a little bit question
for the crew what is your take on
recreational marijuana is this something
that can help or hurt america and why i
don't know that i can help this is my
view on marijuana i don't i first off i
think states should be allowed to
legalize it um yes and i don't think
that any marijuana offenders exclusively
marijuana offenders should go to uh jail
prison
that being said the issue that i have
currently with almost how you frame that
question will it help or hurt look
there are already approved medications
from marijuana for very rare conditions
like is it i think it's travis is the
the
the seizure disorder and that's where
it's a cbd thc there's sativex which is
uh there are a few of them out there for
um
like nausea with cancer patients
but outside of that there really isn't
for people who say trust the science
there really isn't a whole lot of
science now i will say this my personal
opinion is that as we get more research
and i think it needs to be removed from
the scheduling that it is right now
as a drug with no beneficial effect i
think we'll probably see
that there are some benefits uh to an
anti-inflammatory and probably some mild
you know pain killing benefits at a high
cbd with a low thc use from the studies
that i've read and i've read a lot on
this
where it's just cbd like an isolate no
it doesn't seem to work very well just
thc can actually make pain worse in some
cases um and it doesn't help at all with
what we call nicoseptic pain injury is
pain like you pop out of shoulder but it
helps with neuropathic pain i think the
studies will show look helps if people
are nauseous and they're not very hungry
cancer wasting patients helps them eat
helps with certain seizure disorders
probably and i think anyone who's ever
used it would probably attest to the
fact that it can help with sleep
and i think we'll probably have some
science that shows there may be some
beneficial anti-inflammatory effects but
likely at the kinds of dosages that
people won't enjoy right exactly and the
issue is when they say what help or hurt
when you have kids now who can go in to
a store and get the level of thc in a
gummy that your parents wouldn't have
consumed throughout the entirety of
woodstock yeah it's the difference
between drinking a pint of beer or
drinking a pint of everclear look there
are health benefits to moderate alcohol
consumption and that can be argued i
wouldn't start drinking if you don't
drink uh there are no arguments to be
made that it's beneficial long term to
be drinking a pint of everclear and when
you have people who are using these
vapes and you have people who are using
these these gummies that are 90 plus
percent thc or 100 milligrams
i do think that normalizing that
again norm adults should be able to do
whatever they want but when you say it's
medicine and there's no downside which
is not true it gives kids license to do
it you have now more kids saying well
weed is safer than alcohol well you
can't od that's true however for
developing brains children for people
under the age of 25 it is more harmful
than alcohol your body processes a
certain amount of alcohol and it
excretes it okay it's not a good thing
to get drunk i'm not advocating getting
drunk right but when we know that thc is
stored in fat and the brain is mostly
comprised of fat and the developing
brain still has some synapses and these
connections that need to take place
there's a reason need to be 25 to rent a
car and there's a reason that it's not a
good idea to use it
if you are young so um i'm pro-liberty
but i think the culture of weed and
people who for some reason see a
boogeyman behind every single big pharma
representative who's actually put a drug
through clinical trials these vaccines
you know not necessarily with standing
you are the trial um
all of a sudden trust something that
skyler at the weed shop tells him will
make him feel super chill i think that
you need to apply that skeptical lens to
both and i just don't think that we are
right now i think it should be treated
just like cigarettes right there's an
age requirement for it we make it legal
and then we do everything in our power
to tell people not to do it right
because there are consequences for doing
this don't act like the this term of a
pothead came from nowhere it came from
potheads yeah it came from people that
have apparently stunted their growth to
some degree and make really bad
hi my name is dave you'd like to know
i'm in the room yeah no one i'm right
here no you you did a lot of other drugs
yeah but uh
did you but when you smoked weed back
then it wasn't nearly as strong as it is
today no not at all um but i do think
there was some camaraderie to it besides
just actually hurting yourself
but i mean there really is there is
something though to say about the new
marijuana i know a lot of people that
grew it i knew a lot of people when it
became medicinal in uh michigan that it
did hit a new level and that would be my
only concern because my honest opinion
is it should be legal i think that the
same as alcohol should be legal anything
that you make criminalized turns out
very bad right yeah and everybody's been
trying to legalize pod in in the most
irresponsible way right for a long time
where it's like let's sniff bath salts
yeah or let's buy whatever that k12
stuff that makes you eat people's faces
you know
you know it's actually fine the miami
face eater had only used marijuana see
didn't actually use bath stuff but he
was a schizophrenic who didn't know it
yeah that's an effect of anthony hopkins
my question to you though is because you
know okay so people say and i don't
necessarily believe that marijuana is a
gateway drug i know that a lot of people
a lot of people out there who use it
like they might use alcohol successful
people and i know some people who i
would say definitely have a problem with
it so i think it can be used in
moderation by by some people um but i
would ask you as someone who's you know
i don't know
addict someone who no longer has you're
an addict um seeing it being pushed now
on people who maybe don't use drugs as
healthy almost like eating your greens
i think everyone here is in agreement
with legalizing it but do you see that
as a problem especially when there are
other addicts out there who might be
like well i'm not an addict i'm just
smoking 90 thc it's like you didn't kale
yeah well i think it's [ __ ] it's
kind of the same thing as telling
somebody that they don't know that they
have the alcohol gene which i believe to
be a real thing to try alcohol because
you know it's good for the antioxidants
but then you know half a case later and
you're wrapped around a tree right
there's a problem with it like i think
that's
yeah i think when you look at it and you
go this gets me high this takes my pain
away it can make you very lazy it did
for me it can mess with your head which
it did for me but i did a lot of lsd i
did a lot of ketamine which is now
becoming you know antidepressant therapy
yeah which is an animal tranquilizer and
believe me it it helped with the
depression when i did it but i was
shocked when i heard that but i do think
that you should legalize pretty much
everything and hold people to their own
accountability but there has to be some
level of restriction because when it's
not it's like you just said you have a
20 year old telling you like oh yeah no
this stuff's great yeah go ahead it'll
be good for your knee right yeah you're
like really there's just a naked indian
i'm following through a desert right
yeah it's it's
i think it's dangerous in some ways as a
matter of fact they're actually really
not able to serve people who are looking
for medicinal use because i did have a
doctor who said like you know what it
might actually be something to look into
said you know cbd with low thc right um
and i have you see i will say i have
used cbd there's like a supplement that
has a full spectrum cbd so it has to be
legally under less than point three
percent yeah but basically they don't
completely extract out the thc and it
does seem to help a little with sleep
yeah um i will say that uh it's but it
leaves me a little bit groggy i find so
i can't take it every night but the
issue is one time i went to one of those
stores and i was in a legal state and i
was like what would actually work like
for for sleep yeah like oh well this
will get you messed up like no no no
like what would actually help you know
i'm just looking to sleep i really don't
is there something that you have that
won't get me high but you know wouldn't
require would allow me to not have to
use some kind of a benzodiazepine when i
travel across time zones like well we
have this uh uh this is basically a
hundred milligrams of thc with some
melatonin and i'm like okay all right
all right i'm going to go on my marriage
well thc shouldn't make you trip balls
like it i it does it's energetic and it
does now and that's something that i
find yeah really bizarre because it used
to be you didn't get visuals off of
smoking a joint yeah and now you eat
half of a 10 milligram cookie and you're
like well wow hello god
i knew you were right there i just
thought i would have this with a nice
glass of wine i didn't expect to see the
devil's no that's so odd do i do i suck
little nausea
where are you
but it's true yeah there's it's so hard
to say because people do get upset about
it because they look at it as almost the
old marijuana argument because it should
be legal but when you do give
mad scientists the ability to make the
craziest drugs possible they do and then
and now that you know you have this was
the thing that happened with joe rogan
where people said look look legalize it
just don't tell people that it's
medicine for everything and certainly
don't let people drive on it
and they were arguing like well there's
no there's no correlation between uh
marijuana increased traffic fatalities
like
okay yeah i just don't have a date
exactly right yeah all right no look
there is though you should have yeah
other than there is yeah you we we all
believe here probably legalization we've
said that i i just think you should
treat it like every other product
nothing should rule you if a product
substance rules you that's a problem it
doesn't matter what it is it's
cake for all i care but if something
rules you and i have seen so many people
who are addicted to smoking weed they're
not they're not casual consumers even
though they would say that they are
constantly doing it every single day and
i understand that that can become a big
big big problem because
i know people who use weed every single
night to go to sleep and i have no
problem with that the problem i have is
people who are like waking and baking
and yeah i'm just medicating dude
all day there's the idea too that there
can that because there's no physical
addiction they say which they're
absolutely excited well now that it is
stronger for sure but the idea was there
was no physical addiction you can have a
mental addiction to anything oh yeah no
but what i'm saying is the science now
is pretty definitive that they're
absolutely yeah but i think your point
is it's not just a physical addiction
it's mentally like i need to do this
right i get up and i drink an energy
drink every morning i'm not sure that i
have to do that right kicking alcohol
and kicking weed are going to be two
very different physical addictions yeah
exactly and that's the difference i've
kicked alcohol it's it's not easy yeah
kicking off how you can die depending on
how much you're drinking alcohol and
heroin are very easy to die but you can
be just i needed weed every second of
every day when i woke up i smoked when i
went to bed i smoked all throughout the
day i it's just what i did for years and
years and years it's what i needed to
feel okay yeah but imagine if you were
in an environment where you had people
who were saying no it's good good yeah
don't trust the doctors man they're just
pushing their stuff keep smoking weed
all day and that's the situation i did
they're drug dealers
only now they have a storefront that
looks like an apple store i even do a
joke about that in my act when i first
saw a medical marijuana store in the
ghetto it was like wow they're selling
weed where they used to sell weeds
that's really what it is just going and
you're like wow this is crazy
i gotta pay taxes we're gonna get angry
letters but i think we're all in
agreement legalize allow people to be
personally responsible but i think we
have a problem with telling everyone
that it's medicine and it comes with no
downsides okay
joint mug club
you know what i like to join
mug club
you do you do that
do you do that stephen
do you want to join mug club
oh he's got the head thing going
i'm going to get hit because of that
call
call the doctor
oh no
oh no
oh there it is